right the equation of a line that is
parallel to the line 2x minus 4y is
equal to 8 and goes through the point 3
comma 0 so because this line is parallel
to this right over here it is parallel
that just means that it has the exact
same slope so we is essentially saying
find the equation of a line that has the
same slope as this line and goes through
this point so first let's figure out
what the slope of this line is and the
easiest way to do that is to put this in
kind of slope y-intercept form so we
have 2x minus 4y is equal to 8 we want
to solve for y we want this to be in the
form Y is equal to MX plus B so let's
add write even better let's subtract 2x
from both sides so we can isolate the
Y's on the left so that cancels out and
we have negative 4y is equal to negative
2x plus 8 and I'm writing the negative
2x first just because that gets us
closer to the MX plus B form now we can
divide both sides of this equation by
negative 4 so we can isolate the Y so we
divide everything by negative 4 and the
left-hand side we just have a Y is equal
to and negative 2 divided by negative 4
is 1/2 so an Y is equal to 1/2 X and
then 8 divided by negative 4 is negative
2 so goods we could write plus negative
2 or we could just write minus 2 so this
was just this we just rewrote this line
over here but because we wrote it in MX
plus B form we now know its slope the
slope of this line is 1/2 that right
there is the slope so the equation of
the line that we care about is going to
have the same slope it's going to have
the form Y is equal to 1/2 X plus some
y-intercept it's not exactly this line B
is going to be different than this
negative 2 here but it's going to have
the same slope they're going to
intersect the y-axis in a different
place but they're going to be they're
going to be parallel to each other so
now we need to figure out how to figure
out B and to do that we have this
information right over here on this
the one we care about when X is 3 y is 0
when X is 3 y is equal to 0 or we could
say 0 is equal to 1/2 times 3 plus B we
just have to find a B that hat that sets
up this equation so then when X is equal
to 3 y is equal to 0 so we get 0 is
equal to 3 halves plus B subtract 3
halves from both sides subtract 3 halves
from both sides and we get negative 3
halves is equal to is equal to B or B is
equal to negative 3 halves so we have
the equation for our line that is now
parallel to this equation and goes to
the point 3 comma 0 it is y is equal to
it has the same slope as this guy up
here 1/2 X and now we know its
y-intercept minus 3 halves minus 3
halves
and we are done and actually if you're
interested you could graph these two and
see that they're parallel so if you were
to graph these I'll do it just a very
rough graph really fast so this is my
y-axis this is my x-axis this line up
here I'll do it in blue this line up
here which is the same thing as this
line right over here I just
algebraically manipulated it it has a
y-intercept at negative 2 so negative 2
so 1/2 at negative 2 and has a slope of
1/2 so that means that for every one it
goes over it only goes a half up or for
every 2 it goes over it only goes one up
so it's going to look something like
this I'll draw out try my best to draw
it it's going to look something like
that and so this line over here it's
y-intercept is that negative 3 halves a
negative 3 halves is the same thing as
negative 1 and a half so it's going to
be right over here is going to be right
above it right over there and has the
exact same slope so it's going to be
right above it it's going to be right
parallel right above it just like that
do my best to draw parallel and so it
would look like that they're parallel
there but they're different lines
because they have different y-intercepts